Hi! This is your host, Naomi.
I'd like to show you the top 5 travel destinations of India.
Number 5: Delhi.
Start with the country's capital.
Soak in the exciting energy of this fast-growing city...
...while enjoying the landmarks that tell the story of Delhi's past.
Number 4: Kerala.
Locals call it "God's country."
And why not?
This is where you'll find great beaches...
...and, of course, the calm and meditative, world-famous backwaters.
Number 3: Mumbai,...
...the most cosmopolitan city of India.
Besides its plethora of restaurants and nightlife,...
...the city has a remarkable diversity of beautiful architecture.
Number 2: Rajasthan,...
...the state of princes and palaces.
Set amidst a desert landscape,...
...this otherworldly destination showcases India's rich heritage...
...like no other place.
Number 1: Agra.
This is the city where you'll find Taj Mahal,...
...one of the Wonders of the World,...
...an awe-inspiring symbol of love...
...and a widowed king's promise to his beloved queen.
Keep watching our travel video series.
See you next time!